[Music]
like this in a million years unless of
course I'm discovered and become a movie
star that is I guess you'd stays started
why I came here
[Music]
this is the director Adam Kesher during
the process of recasting the lead
actress this one comes highly
recommended
happy to put her on the list for
considerations there's no way there's no
way you want him replaced yeah [ __ ]
everything up wanna know
I know you're afraid of something
be careful promise
when you think of them and money and the
key
does it make you remember anything
there was an accident
klauridsen
what are you doing we don't stop here
get out of the car
[Music]
I had a dream about this foot there's a
man
he's the one who's doing
[Music]
at a very strange day
[Music]
and getting stranger don't know who I am
you want to know don't you
I know you're afraid of something
be careful promise
when you think of them the money and the
key
does it make you remember that evening
[Music]
yes the girl is still missing there was
an accident
[Music]
[Music]
I had a dream about this foot there's a
man
he's the one who's doing
[Music]
it is all an illusion I don't know who I
am
you want to know don't you
I know you're afraid of something
be careful promise
when you think of them the money and the
key
does it think you remember anything